Hooray, moay, boo!
Hooray, hooray!
Hooray,
hooray!
Hooray!
Rust and Blood.
Chapter 1.
Mysterious murder of Annie...
...Anteza!
Howdy!
I wasn't sure if you were the kind of maid that did
cleaning.
I'm not.
But I do enjoy a little clean.
You know what I mean?
I enjoy a little scrubby dub.
A little vacuuming here and there.
How is my nub?
actually I didn't nap but so this morning I woke up at 4 a
.m.
I woke up at 4 a.m.
and I was like no and then I went back to sleep at like 7 8
8 a.m.
and I slept for a couple more hours so that was my nap
virtual cleaning is so much more fun than the You know
what's so funny is like there are so many games that are
just like real life simulator thing, but they're so much
better.
You know what I mean?
This bell channel, I'm back.
Thank you.
They're just like, yeah, they're just chores the game.
Oh, man.
They're like, yeah, you're raking leaves.
And I'm like, yes, yes, yes.
I want to rake the leaves.
Real life.
No, don't make me rake the leaves.
No.
But in game, I'm like, yes.
Yes, yes, I want to rake the leaves.
I guess in games like this, there's like some sort of level
of...
I mean, they make them a little bit easier.
Because like, you know, in real life, say I'm raking leaves.
I gotta get the baggie out.
it open I gotta hope it doesn't fall over and spill out all
the leaves but in this I'm just like and it goes straight
into the bag easy peasy like stuff like this like a crime
scene simulator well not simulator cleaner like a cleaning
game like I don't have to worry about you know like the mobs
are just so easy yeah clicking is so much nicer that's so
bad are we getting too lazy as a society where i become i
become joyous by pretending to move and then when i have to
actually move i'm like ah bird
i have borderless on i'm frustrated because i have
borderless on and when i it's not working so thank you so
much for this Superdance everybody!
Why rake when you can use leaf blowers?
I was going insane because of the leaf blowers today.
I was so angry.
I was so angry because I was, it was, you know, they were so
loud.
I was in my kitchen.
I was making some lunch and right outside my window and I'm
like, shut up, shut up, shut up.
And so I was like, fine, you know what?
I'm going to take a from making lunch and I'm gonna go I'm
gonna go I shouldn't have done that because I almost burnt
my lunch but anyway I went to the I went into my bedroom
instead I was like okay well I'm gonna do some skincare and
then the freaking leaf blower guy follows not follows me
obviously but he goes to the other side and like by the
window that is of my bathroom and like a loud baby!
I want to wear back at you!
I was so... Don't mention leaf blower around me today.
I'm so angry.
So the gamification is that your house doesn't get clean and
you don't get paid for it.
I get it, I think.
Well, also, it's kind of fun because, like, you get the
upgrades and then, like, you, like, get... Everything
becomes so satisfying, no?
to the stream all day games like this are so relaxing thank
you dusty thank you i think so too if the line gave plus
five rake size per level we talk that's what i'm saying
that's what i'm saying sorry i'm like trying to catch up on
super chats sorry there's no music sorry how are there
always leaves to blow i don't know there's not they just do
it because They just do it because...
Hey, but that was my birthday today!
XT, happy birthday!
Can I get a really big happy birthday and a wink?
Okay, there is just no music.
This game is great, you're gonna love it?
That's what multiple people said, I'm excited.
We can just chill.
This week, I have a lot of stream, or like a full week of
streams, but I chose some more chill stuff.
Happy Wednesday, chill game, like this is perfect for the
middle of the week.
week happy wednesday i yeah i chose some like more chill
games because i was like i'm gonna be recovering from jet
lag a little bit still so yeah how did i manage to find this
game i've seen other streamers that i watch play it so i was
like oh well i'll give it a shot too that's all friday and
saturday aren't chill at all yeah but monday tuesday
wednesday thursday are Hopefully I'm recovered from jet lag.
But, ow, by Friday and Saturday.
Hopefully.
I lived in an apartment complex that paid for landscaping.
They were out there with leaf blowers every other day, rain
or shine.
That's literally what it's like here at this cafe.
It's so bad.
I want to complain.
I wish to complain.
Tim-Tam!
Thank you so much for the thought.
Gifted.
Thank you.
What are they blowing?
Like sticks.
Like twigs.
Nothing.
There's nothing to blow.
Glad I'm not at work tonight so I can finally relax.
Oatsu!
Minto have a job interview tomorrow, not for blowing leaves,
I promise.
Gotta get a Minto.
Good luck, beam.
Geek splice!
Good luck!
Bees!
Did
I sound like a mosquito to you guys too?
Valerius, thank you so much for the fine content!
Thank you, thank you!
Thank you!
Cleaning your office, good luck.
It did?
Whee!
Mintsquito.
Sounds like racing cars.
Thanks for making my first ever concert or zero special last
week.
Thanks for coming.
Thank you.
Thank you, Sabra.
Let's clean then.
We can talk while we clean.
And I can be a racing mosquito.
Caution.
Spillage.
Whoa, is this like an opening cutscene?
We got credits?
you can work hard through your whole life but sometimes even
that's not enough when a person struggles to make ends meet
there's a cut it's easy to become desperate oh no as it
turns out one short call can hold the power to change it all
but the question is should you really take it have you tried
smashing piggy banks
I fucked up
Well directed Hello?
Are we watching a movie?
Shady neighborhood I'm here I'm Kovalski I'm not sorry I
needed to bail I have to be cautious Oh I'm not sorry But
they're saying I'm not here sorry Just just go To apartment
23.
I hid the key near the door.
You won't miss it.
Money is inside.
Fine.
Son of a.
Is that how you raised your son, Paul?
Apartment 23.
I'm gonna win $1,000.
Everyone wins.
Money, money.
Wait, there's some money right there.
me that is that real wait how do i get this someone left
their hundred dollar hundred dollars of bills yeah all right
let's get to the apartment open codex well you can check all
the active quests in the upper left side of your screen so
it's very i need to open it from the other side It feels
very...
Do I like throw this away?
Um...
What's the word?
Power wash simulator.
That's creepy.
Apartment.
Dispose of the bodies.
Zero out of one.
Hmm.
I'm not cleaning all...
of this up, right?
Or am I?
Am I in?
Oh, hidden apartment.
I'll clean up tomorrow.
Imagine you graffiti.
You're like, yeah, I'm going to do some sick graffiti.
How could anyone even live here?
What's in here?
Oh, steal!
That's probably somebody's entire savings.
Steal!
What a steal!
I can punch things.
I hate myself, but not today.
What a steal.
Lost.
Lovers die.
Again?
Daily Doompost?
Wait, why?
How'd that happen?
I heart cardboards.
Okay, I think Solid Snake was here.
I want to go back to primary school.
I forgot about things.
What is this?
What are these?
Oh!
Stale.
Yoink.
Okay, we can't.
I sure hope they don't mind that I'm like kicking stuff
around everywhere.
Aha!
Someone's lucky keys.
Oh, yoink.
What is this place?
Why are there statues?
And also...
Yoink.
There's pillows in the tub.
And punch it.
Heh heh.
I have so much anger.
Oh, why Tim Curry?
Dolly Burton!
Sorry.
Is this the apartment?
Number 20th...
Wait.
No, that other bill was all the way over there.
There's someone... The graffiti is so nice here.
It's so, like, friendly.
Take it too soon.
They were quite old, actually.
But still, anything is too soon, huh?
Anytime is...
Dealers' apartment.
Wait, does somebody...
It looks like somebody lives over here.
Oh.
Oh, what was this?
Pennywise, two boxes of K, ice, the usual amount.
Rob, 40 PO.
Mandy lean five bottles Elliot J silent Bob silent Bob oh my
gosh I hate that the borderless is not working I mean to
have you okay my computer down as computers down but phone
is up so please can I get happy birthday happy birthday
William happy
same old one ounce of chronic Susie and Lisa one box of ice
Igor Diane 20p of Mandy.
Eric, three bottles of lean?
Wait.
This is...
It is...
Wait.
Actually, it is an L, right?
Because this...
Sometimes they're capitalized.
Oh, whatever.
It doesn't matter.
Tyler, nothing.
This mofo still owes me 5k.
Tyler owed him a lot of money.
That's what their beatings about.
Oh, shoot.
He...
here?
Where the heck am I?
I'm just...
It's like I'm sneaking into somebody's dream.
Ah!
Secret discovered.
What is happening?
Yoink.
A pataf of a good friend.
What is happening?
Steel?
Yoink.
dollars.
Is there anything else I can take before it was sealed?
I don't even know what that is.
This is not the way.
Oh.
Artist self-love is inescapable.
What the heck?
What is this?
Roses are red, just like my blood.
Now I'm clean and sober.
But my dad's still a...
What?
Can't count on him.
my friends but or anyone else no one ever gets a me like my
dead girls do
poem number three me it's like some poet said man is the
most soulful predator on earth we're just gonna leave that
there we're just gonna oh oh I thought that had stuff in it
yeah we're just gonna leave this here but is it over here
maybe oh no this is where I came
from why is getting to the scene so difficult beer is good
Okay.
Wow.
There's only one body in here.
I see him.
But there's so much blood.
Oh my gosh.
Can I get into here?
Oh yes.
I took the scenic path.
Yeah.
Underestimate dad's strength.
Yay!
We made it!
Oh.
Oh no.
I make my own footsteps too.
Cleaning equipment.
We're cleaning the blood, baby.
Check it out.
Wash your first blood stain.
Oh,
he...
Did he leave this way?
But it was boarded up.
Maybe he did that.
Oh, no, Minto, I shook up my ketchup bottle and went
everywhere.
What do I do?
Don't worry.
You have a maid here.
Keep your teeth clean.
What is the decorating choices?
No, no, no, no, no!
Sponge?
What else do I have?
Uh...
Buckets!
I need a bucket.
There we go.
Yes!
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Okay, there we go.
Clean.
Okay, now I need to get underneath it.
Oh, there we go.
Excuse me, excuse me.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, all right.
Collect.
Hold it.
Hold?
How did this happen?
Put the bucket down at a water source to replace
contaminated water.
Buddy, buddy, buddy.
Oh my gosh.
Are we sure the towels are fine?
Some good toilet reading.
This looks like the toilets that...
Actually, this place is pretty nice, isn't it?
Everyone does that the first time today.
Nice.
There we go.
We'll keep that there.
Okay, so how am I supposed to empty it?
Well, though.
Let's see.
Detergents, mops, sponges.
I used to work at a place that sold toilets.
And these are the kind of toilets they would sell.
Yeah, crime really does pay, huh?
Well, it seems like maybe...
Because he was just like...
was like what kind of son are you raising so it seems like
perhaps our guy is a a nepo crime baby
perhaps i swear you've worked everywhere when you when you
need money you you you tend to work at places though
I wonder if there's a way, like, in, um...
Like, uh...
What's the word?
Power Wash Simulator where you can, um, highlight the blood.
Not wrong.
Was it a crappy job?
Actually, no, I really quite liked it.
Minto, professional toilet saleswoman.
No, well, it's your birthday!
Happy birthday!
Sorry for not speaking, but you just spabic ebos.
No, you're so...
What's that?
Happy birthday!
You are just...
What do you mean?
I'm always just happy to see you around.
That goes for everybody too.
Don't feel like you...
You know...
What's this?
Interact?
Oh, key.
Don't feel like you're like, oh no, I don't talk.
She's probably upset.
I think that goes for pretty much everything.
Why is this place so creepy?
I need a streamer.
It's always good to see you, Minto.
I'm glad you think so.
Oh, fuck.
I didn't know I signed up for this.
Oh, oops.
My bud.
Wait, is this already a crime scene?
Why are there numbers like that?
Like evidence.
Clain.
I need to talk to you.
Can't stop sneaking around and drag your ass over here.
How's the audio, by the way?
Anyway, here's Wonderwall.
I'm cakey he made.
Now one of them is dead and the other one is screwed.
Rupro.
Yoink.
Reem.
Is this the murder weapon?
It's a lot of blood.
How did it get all over the place like this?
Did he explode?
Like...
Audio's good?
Cool.
That's a Shisha.
Oh.
I thought it was a candlestick holder.
I don't think that's a Shisha.
I think this is a candlestick holder.
Yoink.
Cash?
Money?
Wait one second.
Oh.
Da-da-da-da.
Wouldn't make for a decent weapon.
It's literally clue.
That's literally in clue where they're like...
It was...
Colonel Mustard with the candlestick in the living room.
Oh, dang it.
I did it again.
Oops.
Always good to see you, Minto.
You're my kamiosi.
Thank you, buddy.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Clean... Oh, my clean sense oh that's what I was trying to
tell me this whole time so there was a trash used to dispose
of waste see this is why it's so much easier right my
cleaner sense no oh I have to put everything back my
cleaner sense is a thing Untingling.
Untingling.
Oh.
Anyway, here's Wonder Wall.
You're my wonder wall.
After all.
What does that even mean?
What does it mean to be somebody's wonder wall?
I might hear a muse.
I wonder what it feels like to be somebody's muse.
Wait, how do I...
Oh, detergents.
Ooh.
Sponges.
No, can I pick it up?
I think it's a flat joke.
No, there's no way.
This guy is all like peace, love, hippie, hippie vibes.
But then he's stinking.
Using mop here is pretty much as ineffective as mopping
around.
So what am I supposed to do?
Oh, oh this is garbage.
This is garbage.
This is my sense.
My senses are tingling.
I... this is...
Crime scene cleaner and also rearranging of the apartment.
What is this?
Scrub daddy.
Oh, we used the scrub daddy.
How...
Oh, if I hold it, I can collect multiple, that's nice.
Need your hands.
Oh, there we go, there we go.
So, pick up.
And, oh.
It goes there.
Uh, you go here.
Yeah, you go here.
Nice.
You go somewhere.
Oh, here.
Nope.
Collision.
First things first.
Gotta scrub, scrub, scrub.
Kind of scrub, scrub, scrub.
Okay.
Oh my god!
He's such a dad.
He really is.
Apparently Wonderwall is a reference to the movie of the
same name.
This is like the kind of TV I would put on for my cats.
Where is...
Oh, it's just like here?
Ah.
oops I don't know my own strength I did it too with
squirrels yeah yeah yeah I like to put that stuff on and my
cat does a little cat cat you know my cat will just stare
and be like
what great television
scrub a dub scrub scrub scrub
drag the bucket here yeah but I need to make it clean first
no
yeah oh oh oh fixing up alright I accidentally messed this
up dang it come on come on yeah yeah oh come on alright come
on there we go come on oh alright come on there we go And...
Your turn.
Can I...
There we go, there we go.
And you go over here.
There we go.
You're right there.
Everything is so proper.
This is really well kept apart.
Wow.
Oh, my thing is looking quite...
Oh no!
What am I supposed to do?
Okay, hold on.
Is this gonna happen every time?
Drink the bucket.
Okay, very good.
What the?
Let them grow.
Oh my gosh, so bloody.
Grab and place the bucket under the faucet.
Yeah, so I did that.
Grab, place.
Ah!
Oh, I see.
I see.
No, but again.
Do it, like, better.
Like, do it, but, like, actually, like, do it properly.
Stupid.
God, stupid.
Oh, no!
It's too bloody.
I can't believe you can just, like, spread the mess.
Paint the walls.
Yeah, if I paint everything red, they would never know.
That anything happened here.
They would never know.
Okay, awesome.
I should clean it first.
Okay, okay.
Fix.
Fine now.
I guess it's fine.
I looked like there was some blood behind it, but whatever.
I guess.
A lot of cherry syrup.
You're making me want some cherry pie.
Okay, let's take this guy.
Put you over.
No?
Yeah.
And you?
You put you right there.
Oh, yeah.
And then we're just missing
two seat cushions.
Where could they?
have gone.
He's got a cook chair.
Terry pie is my favorite.
Terry pie is so good.
Yeah.
When I was a wee little baby ghost, there was a grocery
store that had mini pies.
And I would always get like a mini cherry pie.
The door blocks the view a bit.
Yeah, but isn't that a little more exciting?
You're like, how am i supposed to reach up here oh I should
be an engineer women in STEM
I I come up with modern day problems modern day solutions
for modern day problems how how how much oh we've got 70% of
the blood so far, you guys.
We're killing it.
Well, we're killing it, but not this guy, luckily.
Yeah.
Hey.
Oh, now I can fix him.
Okay.
I can fix her.
I'm slowly growing.
Tired of this.
Yeah, the killing has been done already.
Yeah.
All right.
I should use a sponge.
Okay, shut up.
Let me get this part first.
What is this?
Oh, oops.
It looks like a morocca.
Razzleberry.
Is this clean?
Maybe.
Seems.
Oh, wait.
It's green.
I'm sorry.
Maybe I'm colorblind.
it's a water pipe oh neat wait
does it go somewhere it goes oh oh that's a faucet uh what
is this he kicked the habit himself but hasn't stopped
pushing the product one year oh no I I know this exactly God
grant me the serenity to accept the things I cannot change
the courage to the things I can't in the wisdom to know the
difference.
Ah!
Oh, get it away.
Get it away from me.
I should use a sponge.
Shut up!
Stop vaccinating me.
Oh.
More blood there too.
Serenity now!
Truly.
Okay, hold on.
Alright, we're gonna do this correctly.
Um...
Yeah!
Use the sponge, Vittobar.
I'm going to clean this up too.
Oh, oops.
My bad.
Hold on.
Boom, boom, boom.
All right.
Check this out.
Maybe I cleaned it up?
I guess we can bring this with us now.
There seems to be another...
Another faucet over there.
This guy can go here.
This room is looking so...
Spick and spurn, so clean and beautiful.
Unfortunately, my footprints are quite everywhere.
Any money behind there?
What's this?
Kathy, I might be late tonight, sorry.
Why?
You on a date or something?
No, just gonna buy some weed and have fun.
All right, see you tomorrow.
I'm gonna buy some weed.
Using mop here is pretty much as ineffective as mopping.
What a romantic.
Truly.
Alright.
Oh, there he is!
There he is!
We found him!
Oh.
Wait, are my shoes bad?
Okay, no.
We're good.
Uh, where does this go?
Probably here.
Yeah, nice.
Oh, this goes here.
Very good.
Alright, so now we're gonna use the sponge as instructed of
me.
I don't know, I feel like...
It would not get up everything, you know what I mean?
Like, the luminal would show up, no?
He's taking a nap.
There's no way, right?
I don't know about a sponge there.
Yeah, it just doesn't seem like the...
Step to death.
Allegedly in self-defense.
It just doesn't seem like a real...
Oops.
Um...
How do you say?
Effective?
Okay, so if we hold it...
Aha.
Oh.
Need to empty the trash can first.
the bag.
Okay.
Oh, this is effective.
Very nice.
Okay, cool.
Made maxing.
Heavy bleach.
Maybe this... Can I eat a slice?
Oh.
Itadakimasu!
I don't watch out for the bucket Why can't I just spill the
water on the ground And like is that wait was that for me No
stinking away Oh at least the It comes up easy after I spill
it all Okay.
Alright, come here.
Come here.
I'm gonna put you right there.
Don't go moving.
This doesn't handle the body.
What am I supposed to do with this guy?
He's nice and clean.
Kind of looks like Osalot.
And MGSV.
Dispose of him.
Fix her up.
Oh, there's some more in there.
Wait, did I see something over here?
Oh, no, just that.
Um, not quite sure what I'm supposed to do.
All right, come here.
Uh.
Oh, that letter T is pretty incriminating.
Oh, T.
Oh, and now he ragdolls.
damn he's heavy but now I guess I put him in my trunk we're
gonna put him in the trunk okay that works uh I think I got
any uh I'm trying to remember how I got in here uh this way
can I like yeah we can just throw him out the window
probably nobody will see this there's my truck Oh.
Oh, I should have gone to that window instead.
Oops.
Let's go the other way.
Yeah, we'll trickshot it.
We'll trickshot him.
It was this window, right?
Or am I crazy?
No, it was the window in here, I remember, because we could
see him from...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Open.
What?
It still doesn't open?
Oh, no.
The board's up there.
That's...
I messed up.
So close.
Oh.
Oh, I can get rid of these.
Awesome.
Where's my bag?
Trash bag?
Where'd it go?
Did I...
Oh, there's more down there.
Oh man.
Okay, we gotta be real thorough, you guys.
At least we have this window open now.
Okay, watch this, watch this.
Nice.
What the hell happened up there?
Is this gonna be able to be cleaned up?
Because it's...
We have 100% of it!
the actual fuck seems like our guy had another hobby
oh my god we're taking his mixtape why do psychos love
classical music so much okay no way wipe all the blood oh
there's more oh my gosh you can't expect me not to want to
come up here though unfortunately I see that of course I'm
gonna be like what's going on up there I feel sorry for you
but if cops were to come sniffing around I could get trouble
yeah sorry lady watch this huh oh close
Thanks.
At least he didn't screw me over.
Oh, we cleared the apartment!
Nice.
Let me guess.
Someone made a dinner reservation and cleaning up after the
mess.
You think he was gonna eat her?
Ray Mack, thank you for the gift.
What if this was the girl that he was texting?
Okay.
Or maybe he wasn't gonna do a weed.
Maybe he was gonna kill a lady.
My stomach's already in knots.
Learn to tie all sorts of knots.
Ropes and knots, immobilization.
Ropes and knots is an extensive guidebook meticulously
unraveling the intricate world of ropes and knots with a
special focus on sailing.
Right, sailing.
That bitch I think so the fine kid did!
Come on, now that was too easy.
Do you guys ever read Nana to Kaoru?
The book sails through the history, types, and uses of ropes
while tying together detailed instructions, illustrations,
and practical applications of various knots essential for
sailing.
Whether you are a novice sailor or a seasoned mariner, this
book anchors your knowledge and skills ensure.
you are well equipped enough, well equipped to handle the
ropes and knots with confidence and expertise on your
sailing.
Disclaimer, the content provided in ropes and knots is
intended solely for educational purposes related to sailing.
Readers should exercise caution and use the information
responsibly.
The author and publisher are not responsible for any harm or
damage resulting from the misuse or misapplication of the
content, if used for purposes other than say you like
how many times are they gonna say ropes and knots
this this area can't have that much blood or oh right
and nothing else in here i'm nervous oh oh yes awesome at
least for my bucket No, no, no, no, no, watch out, watch
out, watch out.
We're fine.
We're fine, we're fine.
It was clean water.
Do these need cleaning?
I guess they need watering, huh?
At this point, might as well sell some drugs on the side.
We are literally breaking bad.
Why are all the candles...
Things change from really, really bad to absolutely
horrible.
Oh.
Are these made of blood?
The paintings?
Do we want to hang these back up?
I think we should...
I should use a sponge.
Oh my gosh, okay.
I feel like we should dispose of them.
Perhaps.
That's my professional opinion.
My professional opinion is...
What?
Is there a head going backwards?
No.
Just funny angle.
Excuse me, Miss.
You've done this before?
I mean, I've cleaned.
I have done a little bit of cleaning before in my afterlife
time.
I wonder if it gets the back, too.
It seems like it...
Oh, it does.
It does.
Nice.
effective.
Awesome.
Can I turn this off?
Oh.
No!
That's very vintage.
Just like me.
What's wrong with having a Polaroid camera?
He's just into idols or something?
Using mop here is pretty much as ineffective as mopping
around.
Okay, you say that, but it's actually quite effective.
As per...
Using mop here is pretty much as ineffective as mopping
around.
This is so much more effective.
I don't know what he's on about.
I'm cleaning.
Shut up.
My professional opinion.
Says Oh, that's me.
Um.
What do you think you're doing?
Hey, stop.
This is considered trespassing, tampering with the crime
scene, illegal disposal of bodies.
Oh, you're the idle business.
No, no, no, no, no.
It's all It's all just for fun.
This isn't real.
Oh, we are, but we are getting rid of it, maybe.
Yeah, we're getting rid of the evidence.
Oh, my gosh.
What's...
This guy, he's just like, oh, yeah, I'm going to become the
biggest painter ever.
Check out my...
Fucking psycho.
car in my rocket ship.
I'm 10 years old.
I'm the 10 year old psycho killer.
Look at my chicken.
Oh, I have to pull out the bag.
Okay.
I have to still punch this.
Too big to fit in my thing.
At least he's not using AI.
You know?
Even the Psycho Killer has standards, I guess.
And then this one over here.
Oh, I have to punch this one too.
What a rotten luck.
To end up having to cover up for a serial killer.
I know.
Wait, dispose of trash and...
Oh, blood paintings, right.
Okay, good.
I thought we were, like, putting them back on the wall.
I was about to say...
keep these, perhaps.
Might not be a good look.
Evidence.
Uh, evidence, those?
What else we got?
Does it, maybe this counts as evidence.
Okay.
Come on, you can make it.
There we go.
She's gonna, she's gonna make it.
Hanging on by a literal...
Something.
Uh.
I don't see any evidence stuff in here.
Excuse me, Miss.
If I bail, the cops will find out what happened here.
Sooner or later.
This might lead them to Tyler.
Tyler will surely lead them to me.
Nah.
Alright, watch this.
Oh!
I overshoot.
shot this time you can combine trash oh you can well wait
what was that oh yoink yoink yoink I know a guy who might
help me with it yeah yeah yeah yeah I know a guy I know a
guy oh nice we're making wait what was it tab not tab what
was to get bring up my codex maybe we can buy things damn
she was just a student Ah.
So that's another evidence.
You can go buy trash only with an upgrade.
Oh, so I don't even have it yet.
What do you want to buy?
I don't know, like a better...
Oops, I forgot to...
Oh, I think the evidence is maybe...
These.
Oh, yeah, duh.
Looks like Rob was a real freak.
i should never have gotten involved with this all right we
cleaned up the the this looks so suspicious no i think this
looks pretty dang suspicious but sure dispose of garbage
bags victim bodies okay and then there was one other thing i
did want to do which i don't know i'm trying to i'm not
trying to completely 100 everything you know what mean but
secrets nearby um but i did break in here oh this is where i
came from closed i need to go another way uh there the
planks down here oh what the guy who killed you yeah who'll
be in the body bag right next He's a young Ocelot!
I just punched him on accident.
No need to thank me.
Is that girl still up there?
Dang it, she is.
And then there's the trash bag that I dropped.
How am I supposed to get in there?
Oh gosh, okay.
Well, we can figure this out, everybody.
We can figure this out.
Uh...
I didn't go up this way did I or no this is where okay okay
what's this oh you are oh gentrification notice in other
words you're too poor to live here Wow okay hang it I didn't
mean to do that jump from above I think I must I guess it's
to the mindless moron living here i'm so sick of you sick of
hearing this hippie music every single night sick of all
your shady looking friends banging on your door and
discussing things loudly in the hallway you're making my
life a living hell yeah it was a pretty tough neighborhood
from what i see this place is so nice though You got some
cash in here?
You got games on your phone?
You got cash in your drawers?
Is that a...
A whip?
Fresh.
Whoa.
What's that?
Heavy metal.
A book dedicated to heavy metal.
his toothbrush why is the hand so all the way there ducky
i'm i'm i'm getting lost in the sauce all right let's jump
there we go oops it's in here there's oh that's strangely
well kept place.
Priorities, I guess.
Ooh.
Dribble, dribble, dribble, dribble, dribble, dribble.
Oh.
That's fine.
I don't know my own strength.
Watch this.
No, no, no.
No, I got this.
I got this.
So I'm learning.
I was just born today.
I don't know my own strength.
Oh my gosh.
It hit me in the face.
Yeah, three pointer, three pointer?
Good boy.
I was just, I'm like Frankenstein.
I was just born today.
Oh, so close.
So close.
We're getting closer.
A layup.
Dang it.
This is why they'll never put me on the basketball team.
Come on.
Please!
What's to say?
Want to go back to primary school.
You already said that before.
What about this one?
That one's unlucky.
She will never be ballin'.
No, I will!
Why is Oceus Spark here?
Why have I logged into this account?
I don't know!
Guys, I will never be...
I will never...
Whoa, there's even more!
I will never be the slam dunk.
You hear that?
That's how many...
Bowls I'm getting.
The fastest dribbler in the West.
Oh, please.
Still got it.
No,
not even, I can't even do the trash bag!
Nice shot.
If it counts, it counts.
What the hell is wrong with people?
Why do they accuse me of inappropriate behavior towards my
plans?
I love my plans for anything.
I've seen him selling something to the east of strangers.
ready for NBA Street.
He's too small for basketball.
He's a ghost so she can cheat by floating.
No?
I didn't cheat at all.
For once.
I'm lost for words.
Why did he record that?
A key.
How am I supposed to find a key in this mess?
Don't forget to water plants and yourself.
Yeah, where am I supposed to find a...
Wait, I want to find.
Woohoohoohoohoohoohoo.
There's so much in this game.
Yoink.
There's, like, so much in this game.
Okay, we're going up.
There's a body I gotta get rid of, you guys.
It's so disrespectful.
I'm just... I'm leaving her hanging.
It's so bad.
Alright, come here, Miss.
Come here, Miss.
Alright, watch this.
Again.
Yesterday I was a ordinary janitor.
I'm dragging a dead girl to my car.
It worked!
But I have other people to look out for.
Wait, where is the...
Oh, it's over there.
Do I have to bring my...
cleaner thing too?
It worked!
Oh, leave the crime scene when you're ready.
Do I have to get my buckets?
My bucket?
No, you don't?
Okay, cool.
I think we have a hundred percent of this place.
But how am I... I want that song.
If I were a key to a guy's garden, where would I be?
Let's just... Oh,
yeah!
Ain't no rule that says ghost can't play ball.
There's still secrets!
I know.
This game is so awesome.
Ah!
Same keychain as before.
Is this the one?
Yes!
I have a weird feeling about this place.
I...
Wait, is he the one writing all this stuff on the wall?
What exactly are...
Yo-kai?
Yo-kai!
Yo say yo guy
These are just notes nothing weird grow grow to be big
Don't forget to water plants in yourself
This is so catchy What is this Use it as fertilizer steal
the miraculous fertilizer Am I gonna get killed I'm scared?
more drugs
it's a cocaine was he using oh the white fertilizer the
white fertilizer oh my gosh I think we've got everything now
though three bodies in my car is it still me behind the
wheel oh wait yes nice yahoo good evening everyone good
evening i think we a hundred percent of that hundred hundred
hundred oh perfect score
oh yeah
Drugs, drugs, drugs, and more drugs.
It's all drugs and like two decor.
Nice.
Oh.
Wow.
Nice.
I got all.
I didn't get it.
Wait.
I didn't get any of the secrets?
Huh?
Wait, but it did show that I saw some...
Oh, maybe I missed one.
Oh, I missed a...
There was still something I missed?
That's crazy.
Blue means you got it.
It was that big.
Oh, my photo with Paul.
Oh, I'm back home.
Find my phone.
Oh.
Oh!
Sorry, Dexter.
But it's no time for walk.
Oh, Dexter, Dexter, Dexter.
I pet the dog.
Very important.
Photo of Helen.
So is...
So our kid was sick, but...
Is Helen still around too?
This is such a teeny tiny bathroom.
Oh.
Oh my gosh.
Awesome kid.
Into all the kid things.
Oh Dexter.
Dexter.
You're so cute.
Oh my god.
The family photo.
Oh.
Elena's health report.
Dear Mr. Kovalski, I hope this message finds you well.
I am rooting to provide an update on your daughter Elena's
health status following her recent medical examinations.
Elena has undergone a comprehensive set of tests, and the
results indicate that her condition requires immediate and
sustained medical attention.
To facilitate her recovery, it is crucial that she undergoes
an extended treatment program at a specialized facility.
This program will be both long-term and intensive, ensuring
that she receives the best possible care.
However, I must inform you that this treatment will be
costly due to the advanced medical procedures and the
prolonged stay required in the health care facility.
It's fine.
I just stole $9,000 worth of drugs.
Oh, hello?
Mr. Kowalski, sorry to bother, but I have some good news and
some bad news.
Bad news first, Rob's boss, Big Jim, found out what we did.
and he's the scariest guy I know okay but but here's the
good news he's not mad at all whoo he is so cool with what
happened and is impressed by your skills by my skills
probably hire you so yeah good luck Tyler's voice actor is
improvising I love it is insane what the hell did you get me
into Tyler yeah what do you mean we
Oh, there's numbers here.
Donkey is 8.
Ducky is 2.
Ducky, ducky, ducky.
Dad's cave.
Uh.
Oh, my cassette tapes!
That's so cute!
They're like my little trophies!
What is your profile picture?
Thanks for the gifted.
Nordview.
VPN logo.
Wait, is that?
Isn't that?
That is NordVPN, isn't it?
Turning to crime to pay for medical bills.
I'm sure nothing bad will happen.
You're goddamn right.
Cool.
Nice cave.
Nice cave, Dad.
Oh, dog foods down here, too.
Good to know.
Alright, let's go to sleep.
Where's my wife?
How is haunted what's going on down there we're fine right
who's a good boy oh he's a good boy he's a boy the nord
verse is everywhere oh wait that's not my bedroom
yeah that's when you know you've made it as a uh mike's spa
and wellness oh no sorry miko But what if that motherfucker
finds out?
No worries, pals.
He's too dumb to suspect a thing.
Loving familiar.
Just don't chicken out at the last moment, gentlemen.
I mean, yeah.
Just shove it down his throat.
Got it in the bag, guys.
Big Jim?
More like a big pussy.
They're cracking up.
Death to traitors.
Oh my god!
What?
With the ice pick!
That's cold.
Look how good of a clean- It is a scrub daddy, for real.
This game is awesome.
My name is Jen.
big Jim how'd you get my number a dead guy in your trunk Rob
used to push the product for me yeah yeah this freaky hobby
and I was looking to cut ties anyway so no sweat but I have
to say I'm impressed by what she did in his apartment that
shit'll never look better yeah so here's the deal you wait
is talking big Jim first name big last name Jim sounds
talking about foul play talk about overnight success slim
Jim that's his brother whoa so we go oh that's bad call
that's the one we just did so wait I Oh, accept the mission.
Oh, for my computer.
Okay.
Oopsie.
Can I still clean?
I can't clean in my own apartment or my own home.
Oh, Elena!
Hi, Dad.
I know you were busy working, but I wanted to let you know
how I'm doing.
It's still weird living without you, but I'm slowly getting
used to this place.
We have normal classes.
There are other kids my age, and some of them are really
nice.
Some of them.
What's wrong with the other kids?
his tail.
Dogs get like crazy.
Like actually crazy like strong tails sometimes.
I think they even want to be friends.
I guess it's not as bad as I thought, but I really miss you.
Yeah, I hope I can see you soon.
Say hi to Dexter from me.
Love you.
Aww.
Mr. Kowalski, your application for a loan was rejected.
Sadly, with your current janitor for any of our offers.
Wishing you all the best.
Leon the Lone Master.
It's Leon Kennedy's AU if he hadn't gone to be a policeman.
He would be a Lone Master.
I'll tell you, sir, I made $9,000 in one day.
$7,500!
The job you did at Rob's was commendable.
I've got a trial task for you and a real job remember
working for me means high pay but I demand loyalty now let's
get down to business take all the supplies you need and head
to Mike's wellness center I thought it was a Miko was it not
Miko's spa Mike's my cousin by the way if you prove yourself
I'll reward you handsomely Leon the loan master sounds kind
of like a super villain name I mean he is he works in loans
no can't I take some of this trash out I clean up everybody
else's messes, but not my own.
See, I told you it was a candlestick holder.
We have our own, too.
What's this?
Pure water.
Here we go.
Trial by blood.
Five bodies.
Miki.
Oh, sorry.
It's Miki.
It'll be a long night.
Okay, we work night hours now.
that's just how it goes sometimes big gem the man you never
want to mess up with or even know in the first place to kill
his own family he killed his cousin his name will haunt me
until my grave
how do we get in involved with this mr clean oh hello hello
mr kavarski i'm not taking charge of this place as a
inheritance from my cousin so my schedule is pretty tight
however you can take your time while dealing with his body
and this whole mess thanks I'm getting down to work that's
what I like to hear I like his voice he sounds like still
have more work to do he sounds so cool history magazine
unraveling Egypt's mysteries oh my gosh we're gonna we're
back in the Egypt era you guys it's
I'm mopping up some blood see if we've already gotten 47% of
it we are so good
is this not evidence I think we should get rid of this no is
that not evidence to it is Miko's yeah right wait it had
there was a sign somewhere
washer we not want this oh I handled it anyway curse overall
I can't open it from this side me goes wellness I can't open
it from this side okay oh
oh I like how these kinds of things like they tell a story
right yoink like you see kind of The aftermath of, like,
what happened.
You're like, okay, so he killed everybody and then washed it
all here and then dipped, I guess.
Miko, Miko, Miko, Miko, Miko, Miko, Miko, Miko, Miko, Miko,
Miko, Miko, Miko, oh.
Locker card 42.
I'll take it.
How am I supposed to know which one that is?
Five.
13.
That's 43.
Right?
Is that what that says?
I wish I had a flashlight.
Oh.
Huh.
It does say 43, so is this not 42?
Oh, wait.
It was W.
Ha-ha.
Mess will always be somewhere.
Oh my gosh, the plant guy is here too.
My legs went numb.
Oh, that means you've been on the toilet for too long.
You're going to get...
hemorrhoids.
Can I clean this graffiti?
Dang it.
W for women, everybody.
Wow.
If they weren't so, like, horribly geometric, this is kind
of what my shower looks like, though.
Like, not this, but I have, like, a little, you know, I
believe everybody should have a little hand nozzle.
And if you don't, you should install one in your shower.
They're so handy.
Women in STEM.
Welcome to Miko's Spa and Wellness, place which you never
want to leave.
Yes, Miko.
Yes, Miss Miko.
I never want to leave.
Nice.
They are really nice to have.
Yeah, it's really easy to clean your butt.
I'll have to search the lockers for evidence as well.
Oh, that was immense.
M25.
This one?
Oh, that's a gun.
Apparently, criminal Savoy Vira does not allow taking
weapons to the sauna.
Savoy Vira?
Green.
Mint nose ball.
Yeah, I mean, like, it's just...
very nice that's what toilet paper is for when you are in
the shower are you washing your butt with toilet paper be
honest with me
I'm not a garbage man I'm a trash collector wait do I need
to clean this I guess so there we go oh wait this is this
I'm surprised he's like you need to use the sponge on this
Okay, what's that?
Keeping up with those pods to eat at Mama Mia's make me
sick.
But that's our best shot.
Getting up a day changed my life.
Okay, that's fair.
I got connections with his cousin Mike from the old school
days.
I'm gonna sweet talk him into slipping some poison into
Jim's family dinner.
Your job?
Make sure no funny business happens during our meeting.
Hey, had a well thought out plan.
Mike and Rick could execute well, but got executed instead.
The meme is so funny.
Salesman slaps top of basketball.
Salesman slaps top of basketball again.
Shee!
It's so funny.
I like that this game doesn't take itself too seriously.
You're cleaning up crime scenes, but it's like, it's
goofiness.
Shee.
Yeah, it is quite silly.
I feel really relaxed in here, though.
It's been so long since I've last gone to a head spa.
I've just been thinking recently, I'm like, I need a head
spa.
And if you've never been to one before, it will change your
life.
It will change your life.
You need to go.
Especially when they do, like, the hangers.
The hand massage parts.
Ah, yeah, it's so nice.
My MGS 2 collection just pre-loaded.
Don't tell me that.
I thought about doing it in my schedule this week.
I don't know, maybe I'll add something.
MGS Volume 2.
Metal Gear.
I'll find that where that goes.
What's in volume two again?
Four in Peace Walker and Ghost Babble.
I thought there was one more.
Did that menu say detergent?
Yes.
I don't really know what it's for, though.
Do I put it in here?
Oh, I do.
Oh!
Oh, I'm suds-in.
I'm suds-in.
Wait, but I just cleaned!
I got dirty so fast.
Oh, just that?
Okay.
I hope they don't expect me to clean the whole...
Oops.
All of that.
Like, the water.
Snake's revenge will go in the next collection.
Snake's revenge is in the first one.
There is already a snake's revenge, no?
It does say empty the pool.
Oh, you're so right.
Oh, my gosh.
Bad news.
It says empty the pool.
Hey.
Am I in the women's?
Yes, I am.
Okay, what one was it?
Goink.
Yoink.
Oh my god, she's thinking about Rome.
The tea set is nice.
Oh my god, they're all thinking about Rome.
Oh, there we go.
What's that?
Seal.
Take it all.
These are just cigarettes, I guess.
Nice.
Well, when in Rome, when in Rome.
Our solarium guarantees a very even tan all over the body.
Please enjoy it to the fullest.
More like a very balanced barbecue experience all over the
body.
Yeah, get out of, got, oh nice.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh my god!
Oh my god, there's a person in there!
Oh my god, he's getting fried!
Corsby.
I'm not remembering which ones I'm... there we go.
Yoink.
M34.
Spicy recipes.
Get it away from me.
34, it said.
This one?
Nice.
You know, I'm something of a VIP myself.
Whip, the whip, the whip.
All right.
Here's a guy too.
Nice.
Oh, stop it.
My footprints are getting everywhere too.
Whoever killed these guys though did a really great job at
not like leaving a equip the UV lamp.
I thought I was a UV.
Oh, wait.
Oh, that's the UV lamp.
Oh.
Wait, what did I...
What am I supposed to do with this?
Whatever.
I'm like totally ignoring the I'm so like into the wow what
a beautiful gradient I'm so into the cleaning part I'm just
totally ignoring like the tutorial that it's trying to give
me
what is this room for how did it get all over the place just
the normal lamp for dark places yeah pretty much um
And then I said said said so dobs it
What's the VIP for?
Oh
Manual hacking Wait, wait.
No, no, no.
I don't know what I'm supposed to do with it
All right, we'll get it we'll get it after oh my god That's
what I call a gruesome death.
Hold on.
I need to see this suit of beauty can be fatal wow wow wait
wow she is just a bacon holy cow oops baked oh no no i'm
getting in 30 please extra crispy Let her cook.
We don't think about it daily, but the human body is such a
soft machine.
Soft machine.
That's quite the way of putting it.
You were such a poet.
I'm just looking around for anything else.
Oh, wait.
There's a bathroom here.
Oh.
Yoink.
Only $100?
At this location?
I'm expecting much, much more.
Careful.
Wait, I thought I saw...
Oh, I did see a handprint.
Wait.
Oh, it's on this side.
No, it's not.
It's on this side?
Wait.
You guys see it, too, right?
Oh, I got it, I got it, I got it.
Ghost print, truly.
Oh.
Oh, I see where this goes.
Here?
Oh, yeah.
Nice.
Ghost blood.
There's so much blood everywhere.
That's like it's a crime scene or something.
Good.
Nice.
Do you guys remember what button it was to open?
my codex was it m oh just kidding play music for the first
time no i want my skill tree here we go of points increased
resistance wait mop gets stained 25% slower mgs2 volume 2
comes with ghost babble as well yeah that's what i said mgs
fans can you help me out is that game canon also wears
portable ops and acid Don't ask me!
I thought you bet the codec to contact Carnal.
Carnal.
Increases the speed.
Yeah, we'll do that.
Carry an additional mop.
Interesting.
We'll do.
Increases mop ability to clean difficult stains.
Up that?
Oh, you can only...
go one or the other?
Wait, that's so lame.
Oh.
Wait, I screwed up.
Oopsie.
Well, we could do both.
We'll do all that.
Nice.
What's my skins?
A trident?
You should be able to change it.
Well, um...
Didn't let me, but that's okay.
Hello?
There we go.
Oh, yeah.
You can change them outside of missions.
Oh, okay.
Nice.
What's going on in there?
Oh.
Oopsie.
Oh, oopsie.
here maybe let's uh let's uh let's uh you know let's uh
clean up a little bit
oopsie i barely touched it i don't know my own strength
truly like i said i'm basically frankenstein i was born
today and i've i've never pick up a hundred pieces of trash
yeah i was born today and i've never used my my body before
dang it
detergent I'm too strong born too clean that's why I was
created
not bad not bad
still a little worried how they want me to clean the pool
but we'll get there I suppose I like our new mop it's pretty
nifty looking
I'm sorry like no one was ever here yeah like no one was
ever here because they weren't
get some new gadgets wait didn't i have the pressure washer
what does that do oh
whoa wait now i'm actually i'm too far away
Oh, this will help with like...
Yeah!
With some of these things on the wall too.
Anything on the ceiling?
No.
Luckily.
Amazing?
Yeah?
I'd say so too.
We might want to get the murder weapon, you guys.
Just a hunch.
sometimes this is actually better though
someone was feeling stabby today all right buddy huge guy
probably a bodyguard swiss cheesed with a sharp object
shortly became power wash simulator not shortly it's always
been
fully relaxed not knowing someone is about to stab him
peaceful death to some extent the body ragdoll physics crack
me up like that one is fine like it kind of like pops into
place but the other stuff is so goofy oh there we go you up
top every time the water pressure isn't upgraded yet so it's
not good that would explain explain it.
Oh, the rubber duckies are even still here.
That's so funny.
Oh, it's dirty.
Oh, am I stuck?
Oh, nope.
I'm just, uh...
Well, I was, but I also got the wall for some reason.
Hmm.
We can kind of get the ceilings.
I don't want to fall in here, I'm afraid.
Oh, it actually won't let me go into the water.
Hmm.
Oh my gosh.
That one gets even dirty even quicker.
Probably need to drain it first.
Dump it in there?
Are we out?
I'm out of detergent!
Oh no.
Oh wait.
Oh sorry.
One slice to the throat did the trick.
Pretty quick, death.
Given the circumstances.
Wait, I want to see.
Where is it?
I don't mean to punch them.
Oh,
what's that?
What the actual fuck?
I've seen people slicing pizza with this.
That's what it's for.
pizza and unslicing people.
What's this?
M05.
Why did they even bother locking them?
M5.
Mateo's pizza.
I'll order one with pineapple for me and Dexter.
This guy, he's so awesome.
Heck yeah, we're getting pineapple pizza.
Oh yeah.
Pineapple pizza.
It's delicious and we're gonna enjoy it.
I'm so sorry.
Okay, I didn't...
I didn't...
I didn't beat it!
I...
I had a good solid punch to the groin is a good way to make
sure they aren't faking.
That's so messed up.
Like, hey, did we act?
actually kill you I think if anybody something is blocking
the way something is blocking the way is it this I'm gonna
put it down very gently gent not gently gently I
think I think you guys if anybody were to be like hey are
you alive and punched you in the groin you would be able to
be like i won't flinch i don't think you guys would flinch i
trust i don't think i'd flinch i'd say i'm not i'm not
i'd say i'm not alive minto punching the body it must be
wednesday don't take that bet thank you for believing in me
You'd flinch?
No, you wouldn't.
I would say I'm not alive.
I'm not alive.
Wait, do I have to, like, put this in here, too?
Or does it just run out of water?
Oh, there we go.
Okay, cool.
It does run out of water.
Nico's Spa and Wellness.
Now, how...
Oh.
How am I supposed to handle this?
Like, how am I supposed to handle the pool?
Oh wait, maybe I'm here.
Okay, I'm gonna manually hack.
Oops.
Oh, four.
Oh, six.
Four.
Oh, shoot.
Screw this.
Five.
A one!
I did it.
Easy peasy.
Yeah, easy peasy.
Uh,
cassette tape.
First try.
So true.
Oh, I forgot about things.
Oh, so the red to green will drain it.
CIP access granted.
Yeah, thanks.
What did I know when that was?
likes to clean.
No one likes to clean.
Price the sun.
What did I access here?
Hmm.
Wow, pizza!
So, this thing.
Okay.
What's the VIP?
The VIP surely isn't what gives us access to...
Why would a VIP have access to a
to the pumps, right?
Yippee!
We did it!
Cash by the fan.
That's the one I just grabbed.
That's the one I just grabbed, right?
Oh, no, it's not!
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
I did miss that one.
Very important pumps.
Yeah.
Oh, man.
My boy.
My bed.
Oops.
It's fine.
I'm sure they didn't want it anyway.
I'm sure they didn't want it anyway because like it, you
know, it's silk.
It would have had fingerprints and stuff on it.
You just want to get rid of it anyway.
They don't want all of this.
They don't want any of this.
it's all what's stuck in there another one another one m17
beat for bobby it's too cold to make it to the recording
session don't f it up
let's go bobby
not the ricin
what's that What would
the kids nowadays say?
Not making it out of the hood with this one.
Wait, but there was like definitely noise behind me.
Did you guys hear that?
That scared me.
He's so hip.
Not making it out of the hood with this one, guys.
Let's see.
Where's my trash?
in all right we got a lot of garbage to clean up hit no
fault of mine surely can't pick up anything with a full bag
okay shut up another one there is a scary mode but this
isn't it wait what's the scary mode spoil it for me i'm so
curious wait what's the scary mode like will the ghosts
haunt you stuff of the people why is that that guy's got a
gun oh this is a real gun
there's a spooky map probably slipped out of the hands of a
clumsy criminal there's a halloween thing level wait that's
so awesome i want to play yeah but that would be great to do
for halloween
okay all right this guy goes over here oh oh i found the vip
vip forever oh that is not clean no taint is safe against me
what does that mean i don't i don't know if you read that
Come on, no, no, no!
If only they had a level based on Akiba made war.
Wait, that'd be sick though.
That'd be so good too.
Awesome collab idea.
I've played games like this one before.
There was, like, you know...
There was one that...
I can't...
I don't think it was this one.
one but it was like a multiplayer crime scene cleanup kind
of game yeah visceral cleanup yeah yeah yeah i did play
visceral cleanup this one though i'm really enjoying um
wipe up all the blood collect evidence
it's remixes of the main levels with spooky themes including
one of the pizza place with own animatronic viz based off of
you know who the pizza place is based game but it's just
normal ah i see wait that's so fine
based off you know who do you guys know that there's still a
chucky cheese that has animatronic but it's like in
somewhere like in socal
oh shoot i forgot i broke all this too my man
Where?
Yeah, it's in SoCal.
It's like, it's quite literally, if I had to remember, just
like one...
Oh, wait, uh...
Hold.
One left.
Let's get this.
Road trip time.
Oh, geez.
Okay.
I can't look up that high.
Just think of the money, the money.
Why?
What's wrong?
Oh, my bad.
Why are we thinking of the money?
I mean, yeah.
Think of the money.
He hates his job.
It's kind of... I mean, it's pretty sick, but it's quite
relaxing.
I'm being able to do the whole thing from the comfort of my
of my computer screen but like you don't have to interact
with anybody all the people you do have to interact with are
like they're dead so they're not gonna give you trouble
unless they're ghosts still oh my gosh how am I supposed to
get that up there it's
just like pretty quiet it you're just kind of like just do I
love jobs where you can do your job with peace and then
leave you know I don't have to interact with anybody oh I
don't have to do anything like it's just I get it done I do
it well and I get to say Sayonara suckers.
Until the next workday.
Time for a bag swap.
Cut.
Oh, I see some there.
Nice.
Oh.
Almost missed that.
Uh, brr.
Oh.
Oh, I, uh, four is it?
Okay.
I feel like this is the only way.
There we go, there we go.
Aw, mean.
If you played Chilla's Art, the night cleaner.
I don't think so.
Wait.
Did I?
How am I?
Is it the pool?
Yeah, which one is that?
Wait.
Which one is that?
You can add detergent to the pressure washer.
I think I'm out though of the detergent.
It's okay.
Let's bring this bad boy in here.
Actually though, I think we're almost good.
70%.
Not bad.
Yeah, I think we're good, actually.
And
then this one.
Oh, there's some there, too.
Mabayed.
Uh-huh.
Yeah, clean that up nice and quick.
Nice and easy.
Alright, I want to see what's inside.
VIP.
Steal?
Hmm.
There's like a light coming out from underneath.
Do you see it?
Classical music.
Oh, lots of money.
Nice.
Lots of books on Egypt.
So many books on Egypt.
Lots of money!
I'm sure Big Jim won't mind me taking it.
I'm sure he will.
I'll consider it as your tip for the night.
Oh my god, he's listening to me!
Wait.
What are those, I wonder?
Thank you.
Thank you, sir, Big Jim.
I'll let him be kissing your feet.
Thank you, Big Jim.
He's in the walls.
What was it?
Women's 18, that one?
Everything I touch turns to gold, then to cold, then to
rust, then to dust.
Weave king, welcome back!
It's not like they need it anymore.
Yeah, exactly.
Where does this go?
Aha.
Oh, nice!
We just need one more evidence.
one more oh there's some blood here too my bad
all right
one more evidence it might be in here i haven't really
looked around in here yet oh and the bodies and it might
actually be this m14 but we haven't really found any secrets
in here now have oh and there's also that room too okay it
might be worth something
oh my bad big jim is watching you swamp ghost welcome back
jay lecon welcome back
surprise it doesn't make you refill the pool it might
yeah i haven't gotten any real secrets here here now, have
I?
Oh gosh, this like doesn't come out.
Maybe we do need the sponge.
This isn't blood, technically.
Do I still need, I mean, I, Matt, oh, I guess it does count
as blood.
Um, we try the UV light.
Yeah, that's a good idea.
Whoa, I think it's a blood I guess it is blood why is it oh
here's something Beth I'm bored out of my mind hubby been
here for an hour Mike just 10 more minutes baby I'll make it
up to you Beth buy me a jacuzzi like the one you have here
Mike when we take Jim out we can sell this whole business
and go freak each other's brains out in Malibu!
She was Mike's wife, apparently.
They were planning a coup.
A coup.
But Jim outsmarted them.
Uh-oh.
Planning a coup.
How stupid of them.
Nah, this one's kind of tough.
Not the coup.
Jim killed my wife!
Yeah, I'm sorry you had to find out this way that you had a
wife.
And that she's now dead.
I don't know why this one doesn't, like, take to the mop
real well.
It doesn't make much sense to me.
Why the mop doesn't, like, this floor.
This tile.
Yeah, it's a real bummer.
It's a real bummer to have a wife.
And then you find out she's dead.
What am I missing?
I mean, I haven't really, like I said, I haven't really gone
through here yet.
The NB letters on his tattoo could stand for Norman Bates.
Norman Bates.
Or a nomad block.
The notorious street gang.
Either way, he shouldn't have gotten in Jim's way.
Or it could stand for Or...
Uh...
No bitches!
Ah!
I'll go die!
Uh, does this...
Maybe they want me to clean up the bullets.
Got him!
Yo!
We got him.
I mean...
They got him.
He's like really dead.
Not breathing.
Is this supposed to be a sauna?
Should you be washing yourself in a sauna?
I don't think I've ever been in a sauna before.
Have you guys?
You just go in there and sweat, right?
I think I might be reduced to a puddle.
Truly.
No biggie.
It's like a sauna in here.
I can't say that.
I've never...
Oh, dang it.
I've never been in one.
I would just be a liar if I said it.
I'm looking around for any secrets.
No bueno.
Since you're a ghost, wouldn't you just evaporate?
It's... I mean, I'm more like a goo.
So...
I don't know.
I'm gonna see if we have more detergent.
And I'm out.
Like, ectoplasm is very gooey.
and stuff.
So, like, I'm almost, like, partially slime girl, if you
think about it.
That's kind of exciting.
If you got shot, would it be, like, this crazy, messy?
Don't do crimes, everybody, because the cleanup is not worth
it.
P.S.
Distinct Kaizen.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm a slime ghost girl with a heart of gold you can ask me
where I got the heart and the gold
nice shot dead at close range this must be Mike the owner of
this place oh former owner of this place I knew he always
wanted to get at me but he crossed the line by getting in
contact with the other gangs and nobody ever crosses big
gym.
Hey, at least it's more work for me.
They shot him.
That's the spirit.
And also broke his arm.
Did you need to break the arm?
Oh.
He's alive!
He's jamming to the music!
Calling in from the MGS playlist mine.
Almost finished OG MGS3.
It's been super fun.
Also, have you heard the 8-bit Big Bang Snake Eater cover?
Thanks, Kino.
Thanks for watching them.
I might have.
Oh, that's my arms.
Those are my arms.
He's alive.
Leave the crime scene when you're ready.
Get rid of all the trash.
Wait, what am I missing?
What trash did I miss?
Oh, literally right there in front of me.
That's so funny.
There we go.
And then all this as well.
We'll grab this real quick.
The other one is easier to get, so.
Yeah, there's still a lot more blood.
Unfortunately, this place is so vaporwave.
I'm getting good vibes in the sun tanning room.
Sun tanning scares me.
That's a piece of work.
Like, these machines freak me out.
I feel like they're...
Like, this situation is such a...
Such a final destination sort of situation.
And this is how we found it.
Really?
Thank you!
Can I get up here?
Vaporwave always has the sun with the clouds, yeah.
Am I getting this?
I...
It says I'm ready to...
To...
Oops.
To leave, but I'm not.
There were no secrets here?
Really?
I don't believe that.
VIP room was it, I think.
Really?
Okay, clean.
VIP room, VIP room was the secret.
Aww, what is it now?
No other secret?
Each level should at least have five secrets.
explorer heart.
But we're almost done.
We're almost done.
Imagine, like, getting this far in the job and then leaving.
They're like, yeah, you can head out if you want.
You got rid of the bodies at least.
I guess somebody else could come in and finish cleaning up.
Why is it gotta be me?
I did heavy work.
Wow, we gotta get paid money, baby.
Oh!
Yahoo!
All tasks completed!
Stinky catapulto!
Welcome back, thank you!
I guess we got everything.
Skeptic!
Thank you!
Oh, here.
Let's get paid.
Hundred?
Nice.
Hundred!
Yeah.
Uh, they replaced, you can see they replaced the things.
Jewelry, jewelry, jewelry.
There was a lot of jewelry to steal.
The secrets.
ice cold bobby nice we did get them okay yeah yeah we made 7
500 for an hour of work i think we can afford that loan i
make 7500 dollars an hour minimum hello
Mr. Kapolsky, congratulations, you're hired.
I'm hired.
Just stick with me and nothing bad will happen to you.
Yes, sir.
Oh, I see, I hear the latest.
I don't like waiting.
Call you soon.
Am I invited?
Oh.
So, I'm hired by the mob.
Organized crime, here I come.
Notice how the room is changing.
It did seem a little different.
Oh, Dexter.
How are you doing, Dexter?
Did you know daddy started a criminal career?
Don't tell him that.
Yeah, like this...
Wait, no.
That was not on the wall before.
My cassette.
My...
My treasures.
My trophies.
Don't tell Dexter that we're a criminal.
uh okay that's the same as before where's my room here sleep
time god i wish that were me he's a dog not a mole oh laying
cobbles in a garden wait oh wait what did i owe that why if
i I am trying to afford money for my child's...
Wait, what?
Mr. Kovalski.
I regret to inform you that your request for a salary
increase was denied.
Our budget is a bit tight this year.
I hope you understand.
Laura Palmer, school principal.
P.S.
The entire school staff wishes your daughter, Elena, a
speedy recovery.
Good news!
The Nord VPN background.
Look, my guy is like...
He's a street...
He's a YouTuber that has made it.
Anybody who gets the Nord VPN.
You know?
Wait, that's a Twin Peaks reference!
I would know that if I had watched Twin Peaks.
Gosh, we gotta get on that.
Let's do that this month.
We'll start Twin Peaks.
How's it going?
I guess it's kind of busy for you lately, but I hope you are
getting paid well.
And you're not, like, really, really mad at me, right?
I just wanted to give you a quick update.
were the one who got me out of this mess and more.
You see, Rob wasn't so irreplaceable after all.
Jim kind of felt he was a psycho, so I think that's why he
trusted me so easily.
And now I am the one in charge of selling pot.
I got this gig thanks to you.
We should celebrate it sometime.
I can invite you for dinner.
I make killer mac and cheese.
Mac and cheese.
I know you're gonna find a petro cart.
What's that?
Limeo!
Hello!
I can't wait to play with you later this week.
Yeah!
That guy wrote all that down in email.
This is the paper trail.
This is one of my favorite games.
Oh, it's so awesome so far.
I wanted to help her escape from a toxic relationship, but
ended up making a terrible mess.
I never meant for it to go this far.
Now I have to get rid of the body or they'll lock me up for
killing that son of a bitch.
You have to help me.
Thank you.
Yeah, well, we have a sloppy collab on Friday.
I just put out my schedule earlier.
And we got a little bit of a little announcement along with
it.
So that's exciting.
Here we go.
Toxic love.
Gopal, thank you.
Yeah, only six kids.
Okay, gosh, our salary is...
But it's only three bodies.
Probably, you know, a body's worth, what, $500?
Which it should be worth, like, so much more.
We should be saying, like...
Never mess with parental love.
$2,000 per body.
If something like that would happen to Elena, I don't even
want to imagine such a thing.
Because I already know that I would do anything to save her.
Yeah.
Oh, the chair be wiggling.
Oh, the body be dribbling.
Oh, what have we got in here?
Beautiful place.
Oh, that's it.
Not so beautiful aftermath.
This is, sorry.
I thought this was a door.
It's an art piece or something.
My bad.
Wow, this place is fancy.
Just like the toilets I used to sell.
Oh, that's trash.
Uh, this one.
There you go.
Modern art.
Truly, I am not an appreciator of the arts.
Phil, thank you for the...
For the five gifted.
Thank you so, so much.
Thank you, thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
All right, let's get mapping.
Let's get mapping.
How do they get out of here?
Get out of here, like, with such clean food.
You know what I mean?
If I were to kill someone, I'm not saying I am.
But I think I would do it in my socks.
Or wait, just take off your shoes.
Wait.
It would still track.
Summer salt.
Is this a rug?
A marble rug?
I'm confused.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Yes.
The marble rug.
How fancy.
Oh wait.
Let's also, um, let's put on some music.
Let's put on uh, what is this one?
What's this one?
No, out of the hood.
Oh yeah, oh yeah.
Garbage can.
Increase the back capacity.
We'll do that.
Increase maximum number of Oh, that's right.
We can combine them.
I forgot.
That's the second feat mention of the day.
Why are you keeping track?
Maybe you should stick to larceny, not murder.
Oh, wait.
Let's increase that.
Apply.
Increase the bucket capacity.
We'll do that.
Determine that increases the washing service.
General.
increases the duration of cleaner sense oh wait cooldown
reduction oh actually
we'll do the duration
ah zonator weakens nearby stains and then oh step ladder
help me step ladder no way the references in this game with
a gun you can do the kill at least a paces from the target
which lets you get less splatter on you and with organized
crime you don't need to clean up the body yourself you're so
knowledgeable death pigeon it's because you are a pigeon
that causes death I get that reduces movement speed penalty
from carrying bodies well we don't need that right now I
think after stepping on a stain you'll need fewer footprints
well that gets rid of my problem.
Now we won't leave any footprints.
A handy axe.
Let's do, um, Mop's ability to clean.
We'll do this one, since we accidentally did the other one
before.
Okay.
Did that light just go out?
Spooky.
The Ozonator talks too.
Okay, we'll get that next time, I suppose.
I almost wish I had gotten it now though Wait, does this
need to be cleaned?
Oh, it needs to be moved.
Uh, uh, yes.
Yes.
Very good.
It is, it is.
We're cleaning it.
Oh, we cleaned it.
uh clean this too don't clean don't don't break the bottle
nice nice uh okay
nice now we don't have to worry about our footprints though
that's kind of great like oh oh it's awesome because before
like you know i would be too afraid to walk around
everything no wait I want to try combining the bags let's
see how we do that
let's see well it won't let me right now that's okay it's
hard to get used to this yeah I wonder if these places smell
you know I wonder if they smell bad a whole grapefruit in
the sink The things rich people do.
Dad, it's all Kyle's fault.
First he got you hooked on drugs.
Now he's got you hooked on phonics.
Now he's going to turn my baby girl into a whore.
You don't get it.
We're soulmates.
We're in love.
It's not love.
This is a disease.
If he hurts you again, I will fucking end him.
You do that.
And I'll kill myself.
Stay out of my life, you son.
Sick fuck.
Oh my god, macarons.
Oh, to be a rich...
Rich family with a drawer of juice.
What was...
They love wheat cereal.
They got...
That's not even like a family size.
That is...
That's like jumbo giant size.
rice
oh there we go that's what we were searching for this is so
awesome though they like put so much effort you know they
didn't have to put anything in these drawers
maybe they shouldn't have put stuff in the drawers you know
what
oh bud oh bud oh bud oh bud
Very lived in.
Yes, lived in.
Oh, I'll pull out the bag.
Alright, let's see.
How do I...
How do I combine them?
Fuse!
I give up.
What am I doing wrong?
Oh, I didn't unlock it.
That's right.
I forgot it was an unlock thing.
What?
What did I just break?
Oh my god.
Push harder.
Oh no.
Wait.
This one goes up here?
Or no, over here.
There we go.
Where do you go?
to the cleaners.
That's where you go.
Oh.
Duh.
There we go.
And there's the last one.
This lighting is very...
Where's the red light coming from?
It's confusing me.
You like the music?
Yeah.
I feel very regal.
And faint.
These people are the messiest killers ever.
It's like they literally play with their prey.
Like the person is just like their victim is running around
everywhere, slamming their hand on every wall.
They're like, don't get me!
Ah!
Please!
I have a child!
Just smacking their hands, getting their bloodied.
Like, how does this happen?
That's ridiculous.
Oh, perfect.
Watch.
Yes!
Oh, nice!
Nice, nice.
Um, we have some evidence here.
Someone brought extra arguments for family talk.
Wow.
This is a door.
whoa neat little hiding spot didn't work though whoa and
this is something i can't see and this is oh well well look
what we got here oh yoink okay i'm just looking around real
quick the girl believed in a true love wait i'm sorry we
just have the thing called human trafficking On the...
On the...
On the desk.
Right there.
Not the spicy Latina.
Where's this one?
Oops.
They look so peaceful.
Not a single one of them looks like.
You know?
Like they died horribly.
Oh, interesting.
Won't budge.
huh we can change that oh I play I play other drums perfect
grooves good luck with your exams you got this let this
music help you say chill and focused
chill hop music great for studying and for cleaning nice
what's that
Since I don't have to worry about my footprints.
First floor.
Yoink.
I'm taking this home.
Yup.
Yes indeed I am.
Chill beats them now too.
Was this the potential client?
Nice.
There's more stuff around here, but we'll bring, we'll come
back.
come back with the light i sure wish i you know had a was i
wish i was able to uh turn on the lights i wish their their
um their light switches worked maybe this too is like a rich
person thing they don't believe in light bulbs
vampires i tell you I think often... I knew that was going
to happen.
I think often on how, like, in Twilight, the Colons picked
the house with, like, the largest windows.
They were like, we're not vampires.
Why would we be vampires?
Look at our house.
It's so full of windows.
Ghosts can't see in the dark?
No.
I don't have that special a power.
I have barely any special powers.
it's so lame oh my gosh everybody just slam in their hand
all look they're just so much blood slamming their hand all
over the the walls they shine in light i guess so right i
mean kind of
i guess you would say like you know it depends you could see
me and i'd be like low-in but sometimes I'm a shadow
sometimes I'm a shadow that like right by your doorway
creepy very scary terrifying and now you break glass with
your aura I'm I'm like an opera singer that
high note
Come on.
Yeah, there we go.
Very nice.
What is this?
Is this trash?
Yes.
Oh.
Well, they broke the whole table.
Come on, guys.
That was a perfectly good table.
She is the shadow in the moon that night.
Working...
Wait, what?
Eh.
Oh.
No, I have to work at nine to five.
Don't worry, Minto.
You're special to us.
Yeah?
Really?
I can...
What's the Wi-Fi password?
Oh, whoops.
Bye-bye.
What's the Wi-Fi password?
Okay.
Did we see where this went?
imagine on the other side yeah come
on come on nice all right this this rug is gonna be super
annoying it's all right when that when do you get the points
is it only at the I guess it's only at the end of a level
next time we'll get the one that like makes it so the stains
are easier to clean up.
I'm starting to get hungry though.
All this like crime scene cleaning is...
I'm working up an appetite.
Yeah, no one will even notice.
Yeah.
The blood is so like fresh.
Yeah, all this ketchup making me hungry.
the paint comes right off this is a nice place wow I don't
know about all the marble and stuff though feels a little
I've heard that marble requires like a lot of what's the
word like you have to like reseal it all the time and stuff
yeah Yeah, and it'd be...
Okay, though, probably these people are so rich that they
have heaters under their floor.
When I was...
I knew that was going to happen.
Oh, oops.
When I was thinking that I was going to move to Japan, I was
looking at some places.
There were...
You know, I wasn't even looking, like, at crazy prices.
Ketchup making you hungry is a cannibalism reference.
No, it's not!
Because it's ketchup!
But I would see some places with, like, within, like, a...
you know, a normal budget that had heated floors.
That seems like the most luxurious thing I've ever heard of.
My parents had heated floors in their last home and they
were so awesome.
Like, oh my gosh, it feels so fancy.
It feels like having one of those towel heater things.
Though to be honest, I feel like that's the towel heater
thing is...
Like, a luxury that seems sort of worth it.
Does that make sense?
Like, if you're really wanting to romanticize your life a
little bit more.
Verified and duly noted, more cannibalism.
Wow!
Stone can get pretty cold in bathroom, so heater under is
great.
Yeah, I bet.
Okay.
Put the Wi-Fi back.
Where do these guys go?
I did not see a place for them.
Whatever.
We'll just clean this up.
It's insane how much blood there is.
We're just killing people in our homes now.
You're gonna live here?
You will smell the bleach forever.
Badees are the real game changer.
I would like, badees have become very affordable.
It's very nice.
They also, you know, felt like a real luxury.
Like, 10 years ago.
But now they're so like, you could just get one very easily.
And I mean, sure, the really nice ones are expensive.
But if you just want to...
If you just want a bade in general, like, they make ones
that are not electric.
That you can get.
for very cheap.
Which is so nice.
Let me guess.
An angry father had a little chat with his daughter's no
good boyfriend.
Why are you talking so quiet?
If I see them in Home Depot or Lowe's, then I go, oh, it's
normalized now.
Yeah, it's very strange, right?
To see them in like in like regular, in America at least.
It's very strange to see them in like a location that Oh
wait, I think I forgot to Oops I forgot to finish
Locked In South America, Brazil Days are very common Yeah,
they only became common In America Like in the recent years
So it's funny to see them in like I keep wanting to say
grocery stores but it's like you know
in like department stores?
What do you call it?
Is that a thing though?
Looking for a code for that room?
I can't see anything though.
The potato chips.
Hardware?
Hardware store?
Yeah home improvement store?
Okay.
Yeah!
Steel!
What are we listening to?
Where's my cat tunes?
Wait, what's this one?
Oh, this is the relaxation.
Yes, yes.
American store.
Yeah.
In the American store.
Oh, there's some money right there.
Yoink.
oh oh oh i didn't even notice oh oh oh i see it i see it
need my playlist i'll tell you i'll tell you all the best
tunes um i just wiped this but it should be fine that should
lift the lockdown oh whoa what is that oh oh yeah anything
in there check your pockets i'm here i'm here to take all
your money oh yeah yeah they
got also the maraca literal money laundering it's a nice you
put it you put a uh a bill through the uh through the dryer
and it'll be crisp there is comfort in longing for something
that's forever gone that's so sad is
there comfort in that I'm gonna be very careful guys we're
cleaning this up I'm not gonna break it I'm not gonna break
it oh yeah I actually doubted myself a little bit there but
we got it so what's in here
steel steel this is making a sound like a oh I'm hacking oh
shoot seven two shit screw this I did it damn fuck screw
this yeah easy peasy easy peasy there's roughly around four
to six liters of ketchup in the body depending on height
weight age health conditions etc voila get lucky find and
open the hidden safe holy cow excuse me does this need to go
back it does nobody will know wait I want to make sure I got
everything it's a little hard to see there we go there we go
yes okay all right we're good we're Come with me.
Upstairs we go.
Aha.
Aha, aha.
We almost missed this.
Honestly, there's not that much...
Wait, there's one more body?
Also, it says collect that, but...
Oh, this is...
for upstairs.
There's another body?
Mm-hmm.
In here?
Yoink.
Uh.
Oh.
He's a furniture psychic.
I know.
It's really funny how he's just like, how did this Peace
goal.
Oh, wait.
Ah.
I think I found it.
Oops.
I also just remembered we're on a different map, so we have
detergent again.
Yippee!
Is it Sudsy?
No.
Body found.
Yeah, there's nothing over there.
Whoa, lots of pieces.
Holy fuck.
He did not mention this.
Does he even...
No?
Oh my god.
How...
How is it all over the place?
How?
I'm ready to die.
Lulu suicide!
What does that?
Why are we gonna listen to her death mixay?
I used to...
She spelled believe wrong.
I'm sorry.
I used to believe true love would set me free from my family
home.
Which I saw as my prison.
When I finally found love and decided to run away with you.
like all my dreams had come true.
Yeah, it's so bobs, yeah.
I never imagined we'd be so miserable together.
You got me to believe that drugs will solve our problems.
Fix our relationship.
Things only got worse.
I loved you, but you can only love yourself.
Now I have nothing to live for.
Nothing.
Jane.
Relax, farewell to this wretched world.
Wait, so is this the girl of the guy that died?
I'm getting a little lost in the sauce on who everybody is.
Emotional final message versus minor spelling mistake.
Yeah, it's good music.
Come on.
I know you can do it.
Jump.
Jump wasowski.
Why can't I jump all of a sudden?
No!
There's a handprint here, too.
Oh.
Gosh, they really just...
Everywhere.
Maybe bring the bucket.
I fear we will be bringing it up and down so much, though.
I mean...
Maybe it's fine.
Maybe it's okay to bring it up.
I mean, what's the difference between me...
You know what?
Yeah.
Oh.
There's much more upstairs.
Let's... I'll do that then.
You can see the city outside.
I hope...
I sure hope...
Maybe we should, like, cover the windows or something.
Um...
Be careful, be careful.
I sure hope nobody is peeping in.
This is kind of awesome.
Kyle!
Yo!
I think I found you your dream home.
Come today, let's make a deal.
Does she meet the requirements?
Of course.
23 years old, blonde, just your type.
Why 23?
Sounds good.
Send her to me.
All she did was to catch the eye of the wrong man.
You know what?
Good honor, Dad, for killing this guy.
Yeah.
He sucks.
Yeah, what happens when they turn 24?
This looks like something...
Right?
The paper looks like it should be something, no?
This
probably goes...
Here, if I had to guess.
Let's clean it first.
The gun.
Oh, yes.
They both...
They both- oh yes, they both reached for the gun, the gun,
the gun, the gun.
Oh yes, they both reached for the gun, for the gun.
With the sponge.
You can use the sponge to clean without- Oh, really?
Oh, it won't move it?
Oh, that's not good to know.
Oh, yeah, you're right.
But we can put that right there.
Put you right there.
What?
I think I missed where this went.
I'll just put it there for right now.
Oh, it might go up on here, actually.
Look at that where it belongs.
Yes.
And also...
Yes!
I see that plant B had to be put motion protocol the mop is
the shoddy the sponge is the sniper the power washer is the
bfg i wouldn't say it's the sniper maybe like a pistol i
believe chat has been saying a bad about the sponge every
time you've broken something oh no kidding sorry i'm playing
the game
Oh, come on.
Damn.
It's different.
This has got to go up here.
Yeah, I knew it.
And this too.
Yes, I knew it.
And this goes...
Where does this go?
Oh.
That makes sense.
Colby.
Nice.
I I can't get over the fact that I like suddenly was like
wait there's another there's another body that we're missing
and like it was hidden that's so cool that's so cool um
let's get our trusted you
That's water!
Thank you so, so much!
Really appreciate it.
I think we'll have to get the rest downstairs, though.
I don't know why I was able to...
I used to be able to jump.
Now my legs don't make it anymore.
Oh!
Oh, okay!
Nice!
Can we take those?
Uh, am I out of water?
No, you just don't want to work.
Yeah, easy mode.
We'd love to see it.
Okay, there we go.
Very good, very good.
Um, there's a thing here.
Yes.
Let's go get the light.
Oh, my gosh.
Which is right.
Wait.
Where did I put it?
Wait, where did I put it?
Oh, it's right here, just kidding.
She found it.
Yes.
Okay.
This all seems pretty fine.
Wait a second, though.
He did know.
Because those are not my footprints, for sure.
100%.
I make you love you.
Thank you!
There's a flashlight in the skill tree.
Oh, that's huge.
Thank you.
Wait, before we do that, let's wash it.
Let's wash it, then...
Okay.
This might seem a little excessive, but...
Um...
Then we detergent.
And then...
One second.
Oh, whoa.
Uh, I didn't mean to pause it, but one second.
Yeah, this is not...
These are not our footprints, so...
It's a little freaky.
Oh, the candle went out.
Is today meeting day?
You...
Yes, it is actually.
So probably after this one, we'll...
We'll call it...
oops oops come here ma'am exhausted from drugs and toxic
relations she went out on her own terms huh yeah and then
there's these she warned you all she warned you all what
stop this is so deadly She's a dead body.
What have we missed?
What?
Oh, here.
Yay!
First floor location cleared.
Is everything cleared down here too?
Get rid of the trash.
And move the furniture back to its place.
Oh, there were those.
Oh, she's also jamming.
She's alive!
FK in the blood pool.
She's alive, you guys!
It's fine!
Come on!
Wake up!
See?
She's faking it!
Furniture back to its place.
Ah, here we go, here we go.
Minky?
Orc?
Get rid of trash.
Oh, we're missing one tiny trash, you guys.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, I found it!
Oh my god.
It is quite literally the tiniest trash.
Oh, that's it.
Everything complete?
Ground floor?
First floor?
I think so.
Nice.
Let's go home!
Secrets, I think we got it.
These places are quite small, so I feel like finding some of
the secrets would be like pretty tough.
Yippee!
Bing, bing, bong, bong.
Oh yeah.
11,000 Crazy
Plus seven points I wish it were more Yeah, we got it, we
got it Nice Complete the toxic love mission I wonder how
many missions are in this game Yay And then our skill tree
So I've been told there is perhaps the flashlight
rechargeable flashlight that you carry strapped to your body
apply unlimited battery the flashlight no longer requires
charging I'm going to grab that truly the Jackson Pollock of
ketchup
increase the number of bags combined oh I see I see I see
hope you play more of this game soon i'd like to i like it a
lot oh that's right we wanted to get the awesonator i'll
grab it i'll grab it what is this one increased weakening
speed and i have one left we can do an additional mop i do
love my mop
apparently the lulu song is real and you can stream it.
Really?
Wait, that's awesome.
Ozinator with a little robot voice.
I want to try it next time.
Yeah, we're going to be dual wielding maybe?
What else can we get?
Additional lamp.
I don't think we need that anymore.
Oh, we might.
Well, maybe not.
Who knows?
Um, the pressure washer.
Maybe we get this.
Increased strength.
Increased radius.
Let's do the strength the pressure washer.
Oh, wait.
I was going to dual wield.
You know what?
It's fine.
I forgot.
Let's go pet Dexter.
Dexter!
There, boy.
Oh, what are you looking at?
Why are you looking at ghosts?
You're scaring me.
Who's sitting there?
Stop.
I don't like that.
Stop staring there, Dexter.
Daddy is a criminal now, but you're still a good boy.
Oh my gosh, we also have the Rome book.
Go to bed.
Nothing else for us to do.
Oh.
Why does the no have to be on the left?
Such a good boy.
He is.
NordVPN, not sponsored.
I could never be.
I'm not big enough.
Wait, nobody.
called me.
Miracle after miracle.
Ever since, this Tyler guy again.
Ever since you helped me, it's as if every day brings
another miracle.
I thought I was already done for.
You know all these debts, no good school or normal work and
so on, but things actually do get better.
Recently, I met this girl, Trisha, and we instantly clicked.
She also belongs to the streets, so she gets it.
Gets me.
She makes great music, and I know she'll rock it one day.
It's weird, but it kind of makes me think more about life.
Or she does.
I don't know.
I hope to introduce her to you one day.
Tyler, stop emailing me.
Does he know?
Mr. Kovalski, this is the last time I remind you to cover
all the payments that you are already overdue.
The maximal payment term is 60 days.
You owe our clinic $23,000 and it's increasing by $1,500 a
day!
We'd rather not stop Elena's treatment, but if you don't pay
us, by the end of the month you won't leave us a whole lot
of options oh my gosh I'm sorry $1,500 a day short circuit
you don't gotta know my name but I know you mr.
Kovalsky as you know this world is ruled by hackers and real
estate agents that's that's it everybody If you want to make
it to the tippy top of the world, of the food chain, you
either got to be a hacker or a real estate agent.
And guess who's the OG among them?
Yours truly.
I hardly ever screw up, but dang, this time I really dropped
the ball.
The housing market's going wild, so obs, obs, I had to mess
with the price of that dope house I had my eye on.
smart home system freaked out the fam living there had them
thinking it's a haunted crib never saw the murder suicide
plot twist coming my bad can you sort out this mess for me
there's a fat reward waiting for you if you do a it's like a
pretty little liars Allison de Laurentis is emailing me all
right well um i'll accept this mission is there like a save
i wonder
i don't know if it saves automatically but how else do you
respond to that one i don't know it auto saves oh the sleep
was the save okay perfect well then guys we will pick this
up some other time um daddy's working for a mob boss but
you're still a good boy you're still a good boy even though
i'm evil um i'm gonna go eat dinner before my uh wow wow
before my meeting this is the most reflective wow oh no we
have no food this is like the cleanest most reflective
fridge i've ever seen guys i think our place is haunted i'm
not gonna lie what is going on there dargo thank you for the
pink i caught some bug in new york oh and this was a nice
chill experience while i'm wrapped in blankets no i'm so
sorry you may think you don't have a lot of powers but
thanks for always using your best lifting our spirits and
making our days better thank you for the stream feel better
i woke up this morning i was worried that i got something my
throat was kind of scratchy but i'm feeling okay this game
is way more narrative heavy than i expected it was really
fun have a good meeting yeah me too thank you Marilyn thank
you I'm excited I'm excited wait I'm gonna hold on let me
look it up how many missions in a crime scene cleaner 10
okay that's not bad at all that's not bad at all what what
is what one which one is this one
Oh, I accept it.
Hold on.
I'm just gonna I'm gonna go to the car and count.
It said with the tutorial.
So, one, two, three.
Okay, so this would be the fourth one.
Look at the little ghost!
It's so cute!
It's right there.
Right there.
Um, yeah, so three, I mean, I'm sure these are gonna get
really big, though, like the houses and stuff, because
that's how these places tend to be.
And it even says, like, location size.
So, uh...
A smart home got hacked so hard that the family who lived
and started believing the place is haunted.
Now they're all dead.
Um...
Uh...
So, yeah, probably...
Wouldn't be, like, you know, three places per stream if they
end up getting quite huge.
But...
Um...
And once you're done with the first 10, you can do the
spooky versions of them.
Yeah!
wait I should do it I should finish the game before
Halloween so we can do them for Halloween right spooky
spooky time I gotta I have an idea of what I want to do for
Halloween but I gotta start planning my spooky games I'm
trying to get control done so that we can do Alan wake 2 uh
in October so yeah that's kind of the that we can start Alan
wake 2 in October and uh have that spooky time yeah spooky
month spooky month but yeah thank you guys for crime scene
cleaner this was this was i liked this way more than like a
power wash um this was so fun i actually didn't expect it
with the story so much it was so good thank you thank you
thank you yeah it's already spooky There's a ghost on my
screen.
Boom.
And I will stay on your screen.
Thank you guys.
Thank you, thank you.
Otamito.
Eat a lasai.
Bye-bye.
Bye-bye, bye-bye.
Get something yummy to eat.
Bye-bye.
Bye-bye, bye-bye.